I identify as a doctor when's your
birthday by the would months your
birthday April April 12th I'm and you're
in April 12 while my dad's April 10th
and I hire April babies interesting are
you are you very organizer no I would
say I'm pretty organized yeah and your
your perfectionist like you do the best
work if you want something to get done
you feel like no one's gonna do better
than I'm unfortunately a perfectionist
I'm trying to surrender some of that
control but yeah are you clean neat
freak as well or no like you like you
wash your hands you've got to be clean
all the time I'm a meat disordered
person I'm not quite at the freak level
so you got to do what a neat freak you
got to do one on OCD type of thing
that'd be fine and I think perfectionism
would be a grave that'd be a great video
for you I should just do videos on you
just follow you around oh here's a
nudist not experience a ajp here's the
video
okay I'm dealing with this issue
mentally you got to do video I'm trying
to figure it out how do we figure out a
sarcastic way to address this and you'll
be my unqualified doctor which we can we
can you know ultra spiritual you know we
can do something about it yeah you know
I've as far as I'm aware I've never been
qualified as a doctor at least on paper
but Patrick I want you to know that deep
down inside I identify as a doctor and
if you do that's all that matters
absolutely so doctor JP Sears thank you
does it help you that you wear ferragamo
shoes every day like do you like wearing
ferragamo shoes and your Armani suit is
this was this kind of intentional like
ferragamo shoes is a that's the first
time I've ever heard that word so I
assume it's a very fancy shoe it's yours
like this do you have seriously how many
of them I have three and I'm definitely
batting low you know I recently did was
a raw vegan cooking show video where I
made raw vegan batt cuisine and I don't
want to ruin the the plot for everybody
but I'm gonna give the plot away so
spoiler alert sorry if it ruins your
life at the end of the video because I
raw bat made out of eggplant I
contracted rabies and you know I want
full meat-eating experience eating as a
vegan so it's like okay that substitute
of course I got to get vegan or II got
to get rabies which is kind of like
being a vegan only veganism it's
probably more deadly so by the end of
the video I'm covered in ketchup that
was my substitute blood it so it ruined
my fourth purple shirt so you only have
three of these that is there a specific
brand you stick to either next level or
American Apparel I feel bad that he only
has three can we buy like 20 of them and
just send it to him on us medium medium
medium extra medium extra me makes my
small muscles look bigger extra medium